this week on the dish we take a trip to
the Jersey Shore to visit heirloom at
the Saint Laurent one of three
restaurants for partners Neely Robinson
and James Beard nominee David Vienna it
finds inspiration from its Asbury Park
Locale as part of the Saint Laurent
hotel and Social Club whether it's
pulling from the rich history found
within the refurbished building or the
modern Oasis created by the pool out
back it is fine dining meets Beachside
Bungalow and the result is something for
all the senses to save her
thank you
Asbury Park New Jersey may be best known
for places like The Stone Pony
[Music]
and it's Beachside Boardwalk
but a few blocks from the water sits a
new siren song
heirloom at the Saint Laurent
the restaurant for the newly refurbished
hotel and Social Club this is actually
the oldest operating hotel in Asbury
Park it was originated in 1886 it was a
female owned Hotel
Neely Robinson is heirloom's owner and
managing director wow space is just
amazing
so original space that this is that this
bar is yeah so this is part of the
original structure of the hotel and the
tin ceilings that you see around in this
room here are the original ceilings from
1907. they kept a lot of really cool
details the airiness the spaciousness we
have wonderful design detail all
throughout the space David Vienna her
partner and executive chef this hotel is
a really wonderful renovation and it
made a really wonderful canvas for us to
paint our food on a sensory Feast to
both see and taste walking in is a treat
for the eyes and then you take the first
sip before you get anything to eat and
you already know like wow this place is
special and which one is this it's a
pina colada milk punch a beautiful
simple clear cocktail with all the
flavor of the traditional this sitting
out there by the pool would be a very
dangerous afternoon
it's been a decade since Robinson's
first culinary Endeavor starting
heirloom kitchen with her mom as a
recreational cooking school and Retail
shop Vienna who learned under chefs like
Michael White and Bobby Flay helped her
take it one step further when she asked
him to help her turn the culinary school
into a supper club on weekends it was a
weird suggestion
sometimes those are the best six weeks
later we were open for service and that
was almost eight years ago so it's
worked pretty well yeah
for sure there's not a lot of things
that make sense when you only have
potatoes and bok choy a run on Bravo's
Top Chef helped Vienna build some
recognition for the restaurant but he
and Robinson credit its success to
something else once people were in our
space and saw how magical it was and
then took a class they were hooked and
the cooking classes actually created a
community around the restaurant
it changed the way I cooked I became a
much more hospitable chef
you know when you're in the kitchen as a
chef a career Chef you don't see the
people's Smiles you don't see the effect
you're having on the community it might
be why I started cooking but it wasn't
why I was doing it at some point I
forgot and seeing it and being a part of
it was so special to me it changed the
way I cooked forever so you had to know
when you were opening this space no
walls exactly it was in that open space
during their regular lunchtime service I
was invited to taste some heirloom at
the Saint Laurent favorites starting
with a hanger steak and potato side
uniquely described potato pave which is
like french fry on crack
super crunchy but also like potato
farmer that's fantastic each dish more
flavorful than the next
annetto Cavatelli and lamb Ragu with
English peas herb breadcrumbs and a
whipped ricotta with mint I like the
texture of the bread crumbs against the
pasta and the lamb because it is so
tender exactly
so good I really couldn't stop in my
head I'm like I need to save room when
I'm not saving room I did that with the
steak already yeah
only to be topped by Vienna's signature
duck with a strawberry EXO an Asian
inspired sauce with dried scallops and
shellfish I always cook it to medium
because you get the perfect of
everything the skin gets perfectly
rendered and crispy a little salty it's
so juicy and and tender all the way
through
thank you Robinson not the least bit
surprised diners like me walk away more
than satisfied the thing that I love the
most about David and his cooking and I
never realized it until we started
really working together was he makes
food that you didn't know you wanted to
eat if you label it it's new American
it's seasonal it's globally inspired
it's all of those things I call our food
the gateway to fine dining it's
accessible in a way that people get
excited about it you know there's
Nostalgia involved in food and creating
memories and and all those things and
there's an audience too I'm from Jersey
I'm a Jersey Boy through and through and
I cook food for Jersey people by a
Jersey Boy what we do is a constant
conversation back and forth do you like
this oh how about this right and that's
what being a chef is it's not just me
from my pontificating from my tower like
what everyone now eats you know it's a
conversation it's a collaboration which
is exactly what a meal at heirloom at
the Saint Laurent is a collaboration
from what's served like a chocolate
hazelnut miso brownie with smoked
vanilla ice cream oh my God that smoked
why do more places not do that that's
delicious to who's serving and creating
each harmonious Delight so I've never
understood the back of house foreign
house divide everyone's contributing to
one thing the guest experience we need
them there are Sherpas they guide the
guests through the menu they explain
what we do and we create a culture that
supports each other they're the Sherpas
they're guiding their guests but they
are totally encouraged to make those
connections with the guests and make it
a memorable experience do each of you
walk away from here each day with
something along those lines I really
like walking in I'm excited to walk in
and see my friends and see the people
that work here and I think the secret
ingredient too is loving what you do we
both love it we both like eat sleep and
drink it the right pairing for both of
you yeah I mean so much so we we finally
we were not together when all this
started at all so that's amazing right
to find the person that you want to
spend your life with and your work life
with I mean it's funny though because I
feel like I went looking for him somehow
and I didn't even realize it I came
knocking on his door so
he was looking for you and didn't
realize it there we go there we go
and we are all beneficiaries of
partnership at least their work
partnership they have their life
partnership too I brought you the nettle
Cavatelli and that milk punch that I was
drinking the Pina Colada milk punch but
one other thing it's all about the
attention to detail so we mentioned that
originally this hotel was all female
owned and so what Neely has done with
the wine program there they have curated
wines that as they describe it like
everything at the Saint Laurent all of
the wines they offer have been touched
by the hands of a woman so this is one
of the wines that has been touched by
the hands of a woman whether it's
ownership of the vineyard or the woman
who has created it yeah so it's
everything has some touches that are
just so nice to see and that attention
to detail you can taste now it's touched
by another one yes it's touched by
another and maybe we'll you know drink
some of it yeah some of the women here
will yeah as well